il règne chez les kills un esprit de
clan la plus jeune johanna à 15 ans
l'aîné giulia est enseignante il y en a
tant de lui poursuit ses études
universitaires et se dirigent mais aussi
vers l'enseignement il n'avait pas de
frère mais à des milliers de kilomètres
de bader feld leurs petites villes
d'allemagne un canadien a désormais du
sang qui a la même empreinte génétique
que le ciel il y en a tant nui a fait
don de ces cellules souches il l'appelle
son jumeau génétique même si cet homme a
plus que deux fois son âge
c'est toujours pour moi fascinant que
quelqu'un accepte de donner à un parfait
inconnu et j'ai juste eu le temps que ça
nous réconforte ça nous réconcilie avec
la la nature humaine
c'est la docteur sylvie lachance du
programme de grève de l'hôpital
maisonneuve rosemont à montréal qui a
choisi le profil de yona thann dans la
banque allemande de donneurs de cellules
souches il était parfaitement compatible
avec celui de son patient on voit
souvent faire appel à des donneurs quand
on est canadien des donneurs canadien
des donneurs américain souvent des
donneurs européen et chez les donneurs
européen la bande de donneurs non
apparentés allemande elle est formidable
pour la profondeur de son équipage au
moment de la grève le plus grand secret
et maintenu le donneur ne peut rien
savoir sur l'identité du receveur et
vice versa mis à part pour yo nan un
indice à
la hausse
puisqu'il a fallu prélever une grande
quantité de cellules souches
sa famille et lui se sont dit que le
patient devait être costaud
oui le receveur de cellules souches le
ministre dominique leblanc est plutôt
grand mais à l'époque en 2019 il ne se
sentait pas fort du tout souffrant de
lymphome non-hodgkinien un cancer du
sang il craignait le pire moi j'avais
peur comme je suis allé dans la salle de
bain la salle de toilette de ma chambre
d'hôpital à moncton et je me voyais dans
le miroir j'avais désir complètement
jambes
mais les médecins l'homme ont dit on est
à quelques semaines
si on peux pas trouver les recettes
chimio qu'ils allaient mettre la maladie
à rémission et ensuite il faut aller
vers une greffe oui il l'a échappé belle
puisque il a répondu à la chimiothérapie
qui ont été appliqués ils ont été bien
supporté puisqu'ils étaient
excessivement malade on peut dire que sa
vie était en danger
donc ils ont une fenêtre d'opportunité
pendant laquelle la maladie ont répondu
pendant ce temps en allemagne en
atteinte devait être prêt pour le
prélèvement en quelques jours il a dû
s'injecter un médicament qui stimule la
quantité des cellules souches dans son
centre lui qui avait peur des aiguilles
hawass
[Musique]
de quoi rendre sa mère un peu inquiète
cherche en
effet beaucoup
mais l'engagement de son fils n'a jamais
été remis en question une vie était en
jeu et même sans savoir à qui étaient
destinés ces cellules souches il y en a
tant de se sentait déjà en partie
responsable du receveur
[Musique]
dominic leblanc a dû attendre deux ans
avant qu'on lui révèle l'identité du
donneur c'est arrivé sur un courriel de
l'hôpital avec son nom puis avait son
adresse pk ce qui m'a frappé c'est sa
date de naissance il est né en 2000 chez
les kids si tout le clan qui était
soucieux qui était ce mystérieux
receveur mais surtout était-il encore en
vie
contact
[Musique]
lorsque la bonne nouvelle est arrivée
les soeurs étaient plus excité que leurs
frères la mère a immédiatement googlé le
nom de dominique leblanc
[Musique]
chacun y compris en
il avait peine à croire qu'il avait
donné de ces cellules souches à un
ministre canadien ses grands-parents ont
répandu la nouvelle
pour lui s'inscrire dans le registre de
donneurs avaient été un geste banal son
école avait organisé une campagne pour
encourager les inscriptions des élèves
il a fait comme presque tous ses
camarades il a donné un échantillon de
son adn
les cellules sont arrivés les registres
compte des millions de personnes
inscrites à travers le monde et avec les
avancées dans les techniques de greffe
il est plus facile qu'avant d'identifier
un donneur docteur lachance croit tout
de même que le canada pourrait
s'inspirer de l'allemagne et
sensibiliser davantage la population ou
don de cellules souches souvent quand on
donne un organe se souvient des dons qui
sont post mortem est ici on parle de don
de cellules souches dont c'est un donc
qu'on fait de nos cellules alors qu'on y
vivent ça c'est la seule qui joue le
bien ni et 22 maintenant puis la grande
soeur à 25 16 heures les parents largeur
pour le donneur comme pour le receveur
ce don est tout sauf ordinaire
évidemment on se rallier pour toujours
lui a fait de son cas un geste
extraordinaire qui m'a donné une
deuxième vie
dominic leblanc veut tout savoir sur son
donneur c'est cool tu m'as dit que
jordan a un chien s'il ne se sont jamais
encore rencontrés en personne ils ont
déjà fait connaissance
et malgré la distance malgré la
trentaine d'années qui les sépare ses
jumeaux loin d'être identiques sont liés
pour la vie
[Musique]